ciao ragazzi ben tornati nella puntata
di cucina buttata scusate se sentite
questo rumore c'è la famiglia e di
sottofondo ma stiamo facendo il pollo
questo questo qui è questo sempre qua
sotto
se non avete visto nella scorsa puntata
che ci ha buttato abbiamo fatto un pollo
in lavastoviglie quindi ancora non
sappiamo quale sia il risultato però
andiamo avanti cosa andiamo a fare oggi
facciamo una cosa assurda questa ricetta
c'è stata consigliata su instagram da
mick underscore z 94 grazie mille
michela per questa dritta stiamo
parlando di una torta alla nutella da
fare in tipo cinque minuti è una roba
velocissima la ricetta ci è piaciuto un
botto anzi se volete suggerirci altra
roba continuato a mandarceli nei nostri
instagram è un piccolo problema la
ragazza in questione non spiega niente
non dà nemmeno un secondo delle dosi
la tua migliore amica quindi la mia
migliore amica satta e un'anarchica come
grande quindi noi seguiremo esattamente
quello che vedremo nel video vediamo
pochino che cosa c'è fuori per fare la
torta alla nutella in padella avremo
bisogno di due pan folli di cioccolato
amaro in polvere 49 strauss berg di
zucchero 45 fahrenheit di farina 3 ugole
di burro una coppa della regina di latte
luther un uovo unica certezza della
ricetta numerose gocce di cioccolato è
un chilo callo di lievito in polvere più
o meno
accendiamo il fuoco prendete il burro
due parà basse li mettete dentro il
composto con il elevato saranno 200
pegasus non è troppo
aggiungiamo due cordogli di memole il
nome di zucchero così granuloso non ha
senso 44.2 specie di grana ma possibile
che lei non lo sta facendo l'impossibile
che lei non abbia idea di cosa sta
facendo
non lo so in tutto questo è
importantissimo dopo che fate sciogliere
il burro spegnete la fiamma di fanny tre
minuti di cordoglio uno due tre minuti
andato un ufo lo so che non ti va di
andarci ma farina e cioccolato andate a
setacciare li qui veramente non bisogna
avere la più pallida idea di cosa si sta
facendo
ok un po di farina eccola cacao forse
troppo farina aspetto il secondo che
andiamo a togliere così totalmente fuori
dalla grazia di dio infine mi raccomando
ragazzi struzzo lo di lievito lo struzzo
lo questo qui uno struzzo lo preciso non
un'ostruzione di più non lo sono di meno
cia calaca tutto mi sembra un incidente
lei aggiunge raga non so se lo vedete
chiaramente due struzzo liti cacao amaro
in più fondamentali deve aver letto ma
nella ricetta piero scusate posso di che
a furia di struzzo lì da qualche parte
secca qualcosa il canale per la
pasticceria mondiale io scatto ragazze
riesce davvero e di una velocità
imbarazzante spatola andiamo a pulire i
bordi quasi come a voler lat raggruppare
più verso il centro l'unica cosa che
attento nella ricetta la quale non
facciamo bullismo l'area questa povera
ragazza alla quale non mi lasciate
il link perché chiedetelo a michela che
veda lei perché non me la sento fiamma
medio bassa io eviterei di andare troppo
strong coperchio e lo facciamo cuocere
per 2 3 metri
vi ricordate quando siamo andate ai
musei vaticani ricordo di quella mummia
nella teca nella teca fuori dalla banca
aiutatemi a descrivere abominevole che
non sa di bruciato questa è l'unica cosa
positiva quindi ok magia è un volto è un
volto depressissimo non ho evitato molto
se è buona a me va bene anche che si
abbassa che sia chiaro una nuova
concezione di fare dolci bravo invece si
chiamano crepe crepe più cari in alto
lato latte e dobbiamo bagnarla perché
secondo me in questo momento è come
andarsi una spugna per piatti bellissimo
il video della spugna per piatti quello
sì è stato un successo da vedere ma
dovrà vedere ragazzi se lo avete visto
la spugna per piatti quella sì che vale
la pena vederlo o questa notte non vuole
in tre dentro rossa di medici uno strato
di nutella sopra dimenticato che posso
dire è convinto nutella è sempre un bel
momento
se guarda diventato un sorriso sta
affermando sta cercando su brillate rega
dieci minuti di lavorazione comunque sia
effettivamente di una velocità bara
pesante mangiate catalizzante cioccolato
coprite tutto il dramma che avete fatto
volare
allora l'aspetto non è dei migliori ma
non è nemmeno dei peggiori diciamo che
la bellezza di questa torta non è non è
l'aspetto un po bruttina
quando si tratta di dolci solitamente io
mi siedo e faccio il giudice è stronzo
ma questa volta lo stronzo per essere
alla mia sinistra se non è carinissima
però voglio dire una di quelle tortura
che al grido ferri e la forza di questa
torta non è l'aspetto perchè un pò
bruttina anche se a me questo aroma di
casalingo piace la vorrei premiare non è
proprio invitantissima effettivamente
non è neanche orripilante a questa torta
e sembra più una bizza le do un sei e
mezzo sembra più una crostata come
aspetto comunque se glielo possiamo dare
se sei più odore e tragga cioccolato
note losa odio ragazzi che ricoperto
motori della nutella downtown zanti
nutella mi avvicino e c'è qualcosa di
strano ho capito che dice arrivo tutti
avvicini e più la nutella viene
annientata
il che non credo sia positivo anche in
vista della soge allora è buono c'è nel
senso cose mi piacciono secondo me se
adesso in questo io lasci cadere tavolo
cioccolatoso ovviamente il cioccolato lo
sappiamo tutti che odore ha solo un
pazzo darebbe un voto negativo al
cioccolato io sono uno di quegli stronzi
che l'odore di al cioccolato non mi fa
impazzire più di tanto
darei un 7 meno 8 5 e mezzo sapore
questo è il mio grande dilemma
sono curioso di sapere che cosa si
nasconde il palato assaggiamo
stava di quasi fatta abbiamo purtroppo
la serie di problemi che è una bella non
riesce a salvare la torta è
compattissima non è lievitato nemmeno un
po in padella
ora capisco perché non entrava il latte
non è possibile un sapore che arriva
effettivamente non è male essere la
consistenza è veramente da calzolaio
mamma mi sembra un pochino quelle robe
tipo per i reggiseni non so se avete
presente in lattice che si attaccano le
ragazze a pelle come intrisi di protesi
altre opportunità non ci siano 100 e
mezzo la constatazione che faccio è ogni
volta che uno mangia la nutella è sempre
più buona rispetto alla prima volta che
l'ha mangiata perché un sapore che ti
stupisce poi il volta che invece uno da
un museo a quel biscotto si è una
delusione che come scrive più te prego
grazie mille michela per questa dritta
quell'altra che ha fatto la ricetta una
pazza un po di entusiasmo in più e sei
ancora però bisogno
7 litri tu parli io sotto al 5 non posso
scendere perché c'è la nutella
agghiacciante è una media tra il 2 e il
6 e mezzo 5 maggio 5 da 4 quanto
pagherei immagino che una cosa che tipo
vai a studiare un amico la mamma ho
preparato queste due secondi o il tuo
amico ti fa preparato queste due secondi
dopo che abbiamo studiato insieme io la
pagherai che falliscono l'esame in uno
studio più con lui quanto sarei disposto
a pagare e per questo by horses una
fetta è un euro alla bancarella
se ci fosse scritto da smi anche 60 70
euro ciao ragazzi siamo grati di questo
video metteteci un bel pollice in su per
il e soprattutto se farete anche voi
troverete a fare questa torta con le
dosi inventate in padella taggate misure
instagram
detto ciò come sempre vi invito a
iscrivere per questo video attivare le
notifiche ragazzi gioria tirapiedi
questo video come sempre l'invito a
metterci un pollice in su per il tag
arci su instagram saprete il fegato di
tentare di fare la torta la porta la
torben padella senza misure detto ciò
come sempre iscrivetevi a questo canale
attivate la campagna notifiche per
soprattutto lasciateci un commento
facendoci sapere che altri mi piacerebbe
vedere all'interno di cucina buttata lì
quando un bacio grande ci vediamo
giovedì alle 12 con un altro video
ciao
iscriviti
questo video sto ancora pensando di odio